[Applause]
i'm just so excited to meet you
i'm so excited to meet you i'm like
low-key freaking out this is crazy
i'm so excited because we have a major
thing in common
i think i know what that is um yes there
is you in the wink saga there is me in
firestarter and if you put them together
oh my gosh look at you
look at you i love the show
so much it's so wonderful
oh my gosh thank you so much i loved you
and fire starter
thank you i really listen
i like i live in the real world most of
the time
and i know i can't start fires but
doesn't it not just give you an
eyebrow raise a little boost of
confidence to know that you can blow
something
someone up does that work for you i mean
just being able to have that at the tip
of your
your fingers i mean that's that's
something special i'll tell you that
i mean it really does like when i was
seven i knew
obviously i couldn't by the way when i
was seven there was no cgi there's like
one cgi fireball
it's like the big ender epic fireball
and it looks like you know what it's
terrible
everything on our set was real fire
you're
also surrounded in real fire too right
well i mean a lot of it was cgi i mean
we were basically
just pretending to play with fire the
entire time some of it was practical but
most of it was i would be connected to
these like
lights and i'd just be staring into the
lights but
not i can't imagine doing full-on was
that terrifying
well it was just so weird you're like oh
that guy's on fire okay that's lunch
and you know everyone was on fire
for real and they didn't have like
protection on that they just put this
like weird
gel all over everyone and was like good
luck it was the early 80s
oh my god did anyone ever get injured
no no sirius
again early 80s now in the winx saga
you're really hitting the genre
perfectly on its head and it's working
it's number one
people are freaking out how do you feel
it doesn't feel real one like it's a
weird thing to
to see on your i don't know on your tv
i mean as an actress and it's also i
mean the response has been so
overwhelming and just kind and amazing
now there is a little story about your
eyebrows
will you please elaborate
a lab brow wait oh
yes so eyebrow gate this
is a this is a story and i am can't
believe i'm exposing myself
but i love it i growing up as a redhead
i had very just i have transparent
eyelashes and transparent eyebrows so
it's a
it's a thing when you grow up and it's
like you know begging your mom
like in i think i was like in second
grade to just let me put mascara on
and i found this wonderful beauty hack
of
tinting my lashes and tinting my
eyebrows but um
yeah uh it was the first time it went
horribly wrong
um on set of filming
god do we have a picture oh no
no i like my hair i have red
hair and they're black they're black i
look like mr bean
i think we even have maybe a side by
side of you and
rowan atkinson
[Laughter]
i love that eyebrow story and i actually
have
a product uh for you and what i wanted
to do
is i am going to send you i make um
this mascara it's called lash warrior
and the reason i'm sending this to you
is because
it's a brown mascara if you have the
right tone of brown
it's so beautiful on your pupils
and on your skin tone so i'm sending
this to you
and then i also have this little um
this is really great because it has like
a little soft brush on the end
and then this is also i have a really
really fair color and it's a spoolie
color for your brows so i'm gonna send
you
a little i love kit kara flower beauty
to beautiful abigail
oh my gosh thank you well it's only
fitting because
actually you brought me something which
i'm very excited about and i got to tell
you
it smells delicious can you please tell
me
about this sugar cookie recipe and your
keto right
i have tried keto um probably will never
try it again but
you know did you put like bacon on top
of a burger
on top of a steak on top of i think i
just didn't do it right at all
i think i literally just stuck to like
cheese and
meat so everyone around me was like abby
you're literally eating like mcdonald's
for every meal like
calm down exactly but with that being
said
i found this recipe for
keto cookies you mean these bad boys
for you to try them i just want to warn
you though
they do taste similar to air
they smell really good i i
if they taste a percent of what they
smell let's see
let's how do they oh
is that good oh i applaud
your efforts
no no please make more tell me how it
how it turns out
i love that you're drinking you're
trying to get rid of the day
and i'm like licking like it's like that
i took the kind of bite where like i
should have shoved it to the back
palette and said i went like
everywhere in my teeth thank you abigail
fate the wink saga number one show is
streaming now on netflix
[Music]
you